الان نحن نقف امام مستشفى القدس هذا
المستشفى الذي حوصر وقصف وهدد وطلب
بالاخلاء من قوات الاحتلال الان هذا
المستشفى حرق بفعل قوات الاحتلال ودمر
بشكل واضح وملحوظ وانسحبت قوات الاحتلال
علما ان قوات الاحتلال انسحبت من هذا
المكان قبل ايام والان نرصد هذا الدمار
الكبير في منطقه تل الهواء وليس فقط في
مستشفى القدس لكن مستشفى القدس له اهميه
كبيره لان هذا المستشفى يتبع لجمعيه
الهلال الاحمر
ولديه تنسيق ويعني مكانه دوليه اعلى من اي
مستشفى اخر لكن قوات الاحتلال لم تراعي
هذه المكانه وعملت على تدمير هذا المستشفى
وممتلكات هذا المستشفى بشكل واضح وملحوظ
حيث هذه النيران اشتعلت داخل المستشفى في
مختلف الاقسام والان هو محترق بشكل شبه
كامل يبدو ان بعض النازحين الذين كانوا
متواجدين في داخل المستشفى وطلبوا بالاخ
يعملون على اخلاء بعض المعدات وبعض
الادوات التي بقيت
من بعد نزوحهم لمرات المره الاولى كانت من
البيوت والمره الثانيه كانت من داخل
المستشفى هذا المشهد هو بوابه
المستشفى هي محترقه وال والواضح بشكل كامل
ان هنا كان مركز قوات
الاحتلال طبعا في هذا المكان قوات
الاحتلال تعمدت في تدمير كل السيارات لكن
غالبيه هذه السيارات هي سيارات اسعاف تتبع
لجمعيه الهلال الاحمر في هذا المشهد هو
بات بشكل واضح تعمد الاحتلال على تدمير كل
هذه السيارات
وا يعني تجريف كل ما تبقى في مكان واحد
لكن غالبيه هذه السيارات بعد ان قامت
اليات الاحتلال بتجميعها في مكان واحد
وتدميرها بشكل واضح وكامل غالبيه هذه الس
يارات هي بشكل واضح تابع للهلال الاحمر
هذه الجمعيه التي تعمل بتنسيق دولي ولها
حصانه دوليه وحمايه دوليه رجعنا بعد
الهدوء اللي صار في الانسحاب اللي صار في
منطقه ت الهواء ما لقنا نا بيوت البيوت
كلها مدمره ولا ماوى نا هلقيت وين نروح مش
عارفين وين نقعد مش معروف كنا قاعدين في
مستشفى القدس المستشفى الان محروقه
كلياتها روح تفرج عليها كيف من جو ولا
مكان نقم فيه ولا مكان ننام فيه واولادنا
مشردين واهلينا مش عارفين وين مكانهم هذا
الحال اللي وصلنا له احنا بدنا حد يساعدنا
ويقف معنا ويطلع لنا في الوضع الموجود
حاليا نحن الان في المنطقه الخلفيه
لمستشفى القدس وهي منطقه ابراج تل الهواء
هي المنطقه الشرقيه الواقعه من منطقه
مستشفى القدس هذه المنطقه التي تحتوي على
مجموعه كبيره من الابراج بما لا تقل او لا
يقل عن 20 عن 40 برجا عفوا هذه المنطقه كل
برج مكون من حي سكني كامل ما لا يقل عن 40
شقه سكنيه اصبحت هذه الابراج هي عباره عن
عن اكوام من الركام في هذا المشهد اكثر من
برج دمر والبعض الاخر اصبح لا يصلح للسكن
بسبب الدمار الكبير الكثير من الابراج
دمرت والكثير من هذه الابراج اسفل ركامها
الكثير من الجثث التي لم يستطيع اي من
الطواقم
اخراجها مجموعه كبيره من هذه الابراج الان
هي
ركام حل الدمار والخراب في هذه المنطقه
بشكل واضح وبشكل ملحوظ وبشكل كبير
بالاضافه الا الى ان تمركز قوات الاحتلال
واضحا في هذه المنطقه حيث هذه الكثبان
الرمنيه كانت هي عباره عن
مناطق حاميه لاليات الاحتلال او حينما
يدخل الاحتلال منطقه يضع بعض الكثبان
الرمليه لتكون هذه الكثبان هي حمايه
لاليات وجنوده في اي مكان يتواجد فيه الان
ما بين هذه الابراج يعني حتى هذه اللحظه
ما يقارب ثمانيه الى تسع ابراج هي مدمره
مرا بشكل كامل والكثير من الابراج الاخرى
هي غير صالحه لسكن بيجي 15 مره انتقلنا من
منطقه لمنطقه عشان نحمي حالنا وحامي رب
العالمين تدمرنا يعني مش قادرين نتحمل
اكثر من هيك حجم الدمار لا يوصف لا يوصف
حجم الدمار وين بتنظر بتلاقي في دمار
وخراب وهدم بيوت واطفال مرمين في الشوارع
ونسوان وحريم هذا الحي اصابه الكثير من
الدمار بعد انسحاب قوات الاحتلال من هذا
المكان تكشفت الخيوط وظهر حجم هذا الدمار
من منطقه تل الهواء اسماعيل الغول الجزيره